moi je veux raconter leur histoire moi
je trouve qu on est un peu un crime spi
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui me
disent qu'à 50% de ses amis je lisais
stu un
pourquoi aurait-il pour à savoir une 90%
moi je comprends pas ron cned et aux
missions l'étudiant en journalisme
prépare depuis des mois un projet sur
les psychostimulants que ses pairs
consomme sans prescription pour mieux
performer
aujourd'hui il a eu rendez vous avec un
étudiant qui en vend la revente de
psychostimulants est illégal la
possession sans prescription aussi nous
avons donc accepté de protéger
l'identité de ce vendeur
nous l'appellerons s je veux le savoir
la transaction comment que ça se passe
oui c'est vraiment facile
presque trop facile j'ai vu des gens qui
cherchaient des psychostimulants sur
facebook
jack white j'ai même remis une pilule
quelqu'un dans la bibliothèque
cinq personnes en état les étudiants
sans fond où beaucoup avec sourire et
combien d'étudiants consensus tu mens
pas pour le tdah
mais pour y installer je dirais que tout
le monde a essayé c'est partout elle
les psychostimulants sont partout c'est
sans doute exagéré mais de nombreux
étudiants confirme la popularité de ces
médicaments sont habituellement prescrit
contre le trouble du déficit de
l'attention avec ou sans hyperactivité
le tdah selon les recherches surtout
américaines le pourcentage d'étudiants
post secondaire qui détournent ces
médicaments des fins de performances
varient entre 8 et 43%
l'écart est énorme pas facile de
documenter une pratique qui est à la
fois banale et taboo ouvertement mais
l'important est chaîne phare est un des
rares à vouloir une discussion franche à
visage découvert étudiant en
communication n'est peut-être pas fier
de ce qu'il appelle ses petites façon
pour affronter la compétition mais il
est heureux de ce que ça lui apporte
depuis le premier jour on sent la
première fois j'en ai fait je me
rappelle j'avais 18 ans nous en restait
à ma deuxième année de cégep
j'étais plein le café tinian j'avais mes
écouteurs je termine devant le matin
puis je me suis levé la chance à 4 à
l'après midi j'étais hyper productif à
quel point ça s'appelle mais j'arrive à
l'époque un effet whaou qui le pousse
trois ans plus tard à continuer d'en
prendre en mi session et en fin de
session pour être plus concentré et
avoir de meilleures notes
comme il n'y a pas de prescription il se
tourne vers ses ennemis
j'ai beaucoup d'amitié prescription
pourrait
là vivent ce qu'ils soient concertés
vitaly s'est fait que tu aies l'embarras
du choix
ouais ça c'est quelque chose qui est un
petit peu pesant sur ces lieux qui sont
prescrits et ils prennent plaisir à
prendre ce trou fait qu'il en reste
souvent beaucoup puis savoir dérange pas
abandonner ou quoi que ce soit c'est le
cas de hesse qui vend ses médicaments
qu'il n'a pas consommé
ça lui rapporte environ 700 dollars tous
les trois mois
son argent de poche à montréal pour une
pilule de 30 mg c'est environ 10 dollars
mg 15 dollars pendant les examens la
demande est plus forte donc je vend plus
cher à toronto à l'université de toronto
c'est un dollar le mini grable c'est fou
une pilule de 30 mg coûts en dollars
ça prouve que la demande ya des
psychostimulants en abondance au québec
comparons avec le reste du canada chez
les 0 à 25 ans on trouve ici trois fois
plus de consommateurs de médicaments
contre le tdah
selon les données de la régie de
l'assurance maladie du québec la ramq eu
les montants payés pour ces médicaments
sont passées de 20 millions à 58
millions de dollars en 10 ans ajoutons à
cela les montants versés par les
assurances privées qui couvre plus de la
moitié de la population
[Musique]
le plus on a de ces médicaments là en
circulation c'est certain qu'il ya deux
possibilités plus grand qu'on puisse
avoir des utilisations non médical le
docteur nicolas chadi de l'hôpital
sainte justine est le premier
spécialiste en amérique du nord formée
en toxicomanie pédiatrique
les jeunes ne pense pas que d'utiliser
des psychostimulants des fins
récréatives wade fait une performance ça
peut être dangereux
on a grande majorité des cas ils peuvent
céder 6 et prescrire des enfants si
c'est prescrit à mon avis pourquoi ça
serait risqué que moi je ne m'aime gens
fassent l'utilisation une prise de
conscience qui est à faire
il faut aussi éduquer le grand public à
savoir c'est pas des médicaments qui
sont bilingues fit définitivement ya des
risques qui y sont associés
ces médicaments stimule le système
nerveux central et certains sont à base
d'amphétamines
santé canada fait état des risques
associés à la consommation problématique
de stimulants l'hypertension épisode
psychotique crises cardiaques les
accidents vasculaires cérébrales
le fabricant du vivant ce mentionne que
l' usage inapproprié des amphétamines
peut entraîner des effets indésirables
cardiovasculaires graves et la mort
subite
le docteur chadi se préoccupe également
des risques de dépendances
ce sont des médicaments qui peuvent
amener une certaine sensation perçue
comme favorisant chez certains jeunes
donc à bonne dose d'anti prescrit
médicalement on n'a pas vraiment de cet
effet là mais aussi possibilité de
consommer ces médicaments d'autres
façons par inhalation par exemple mais
ça ça peut être des comportements qui
amène plus de réseau dépendance et puis
expliquer la popularité de finale qui
consomment de façon récréative dans une
bière un cocktail ça remplace les autres
stimulants
mes amis et moi ont fait salle 2 av ace
a reçu un diagnostic de tdah lorsqu'il
était enfant il assure qu'il connaît
bien ces médicaments et sait jouer avec
ces doses pour étudier et faire la fête
mais il s'inquiète pour ses amis j'ai
des amis qui en prennent chaque jour ils
savent plus tu dis sans ça je sais dire
aux gens ne devient pas dépendantes si
tu peux travailler ça stimule a continué
exterio et culturels
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup de gens qui me contacter
ou qui pensent sur facebook des gens qui
disent là j'ai pris quatre pylônes
d'alors roger prix du vin au lieu du a
droit puis je me sens pas bien
ces étudiants qui se lance tête baissée
dans la consommation de psychostimulants
préoccupe bureau une kennedy
il prépare un balado dans l'espoir de
réveiller les consciences
quand tu mets ton corps ou ta santé
mentale en danger pour m c'est là où que
ça devient dangereux
c'est là où que on doit comme société on
doit se demander des questions comme
pourquoi qu'on met autant de voir dans
les notes
raouf sali hile nicolas cet amour sont
étudiants en droit à l'université de
montréal
une faculté contingenter ou la pression
de performer est palpable
les rumeurs de consommation de
psychostimulants tenace
pour en avoir le coeur net ils ont fait
une enquête appuyée par leur journal
le pigeon dissidents c'est sûr que notre
sondage c'est fait de façon silencieuse
on avait une 350 répond dans un
grondement d'assas et solide ils ont
noté que plus de huit pour cent des
répondants ont déjà consommé des drogues
de performance a nettement eu une
discussion qu'on a eue avec plusieurs
étudiants j'aurais pu penser que c'est
plus bas je crois vraiment que les
psychostimulants son vous vu comme une
forme de solution à un problème de
stress d'anxiété une part de pas réussir
c'est un premier constat ils ne
s'arrêteront pas là
armés de leurs sondages vont se débattre
pour contrer ce petit pacte avec le
diable
la société de performance et c'est là la
traduction ou digne d'un grand
déséquilibre chez l'être humain où il
n'arrive à se définir que en fonction
d'un résultat à une action sa valeur en
ailier que au résultat qu'on se fout du
processus c'est le résultat qui compte
[Musique]
le neuroscientifique joël monzée s'était
habillé à la campagne en quête
d'équilibré
son credo plus de thérapie - pilule il a
déjà écrit un livre médicaments et
performance humaine
une association qui jugent nocive
le médicament a pris une place
omniprésent dans notre vie et pour
certaines personnes ça leur sauve la vie
j'ai aucun doute là dedans mais à quel
moment est ce que on passe d'une
thérapie pharmacologique nécessaire pour
le progressivement l'utiliser pour
d'autres fins que ce soit du dopage
sportif que ce soit du dopage
professionnels de pages cognitif de
manière à atteindre une performance
désiré le cerveau c'est son dada
entre autres tout ce qui touche les
émotions et le comportement des jeunes
il trace un parallèle entre le dopage
sportif et les usages de
psychostimulants selon lui ils doivent
faire l'objet du même examen minutieux
le monde sportif a fait une réflexion
sur l'usagé médicament à usage santé
versus un usage performances sportives
et c'est comme si on ne veut pas aborder
ce questionnement dans le domaine
cognitif
pourquoi parce que la performance est
omniprésente
parce que je me suis rien si je ne
performe pas et à partir de là c'est que
toute l'expérience humaine est résumée
au résultat comme dans le monde du sport
comme si toute l'expérience sportive
était résumée à un podium aux jeux
olympiques
comme dans l'univers du sport des voix
s'élèvent pour affirmer qu utiliser des
psychostimulants c'est tricher et une
faveur qui a beaucoup réfléchi à la
question n'est pas d'accord mais il
reconnaît que le système doit changer ça
revient que c'est notre choix personnel
afin de français mais je pense que c'est
une partie de la faute au système
scolaire de comment c'est fait et à
seulement de l'enfance mis sur les
résultats et non comme le processus donc
si na qu aucune importance à comment on
fait pour avoir su mettre la main
pourquoi je pourrais pas prendre quelque
chose qui mènerait à bord de mer
selon le docteur chadi rien ne prouve
que les psychostimulants permettront à
étienne d'atteindre son but il reste que
même l'effet contraire une chose très
intéressante à savoir c'est que dans les
rangs des études on voit que
l'utilisation de psychostimulants quand
ce n'est pas prescrit pour un médecin
même si ces prix pour des fins de
performance s'est s'associé à des
rendements scolaires et professionnelles
plus bas à ce que c'est parce que
justement on n'a pas pris la bonne dose
la bonne quantité on a glissé en brûlant
notre ou prix je pense que ça vient
mettre l'accent sur l'importance avec
ces médicaments là d'avoir un bon suivi
médical
on a un constat pour nous fait avec
toute enquête qui en réalité
psychostimulants qu'epic lt lt
importante d'anxiété généralisée donc
mettons qu'on a ce premier constat le
qu'est ce qu'on fait nicolas et raouf
sont allés rencontrer la doyenne de
leurs facultés france houle pour
discuter des suites à donner à leur
sondage c'est alarmant il faudrait mieux
comprendre un peu ce qui ce passe et
pourquoi les étudiants
ces étudiants seuls 8% pensent que c'est
la façon de faire pour arriver à
compléter le programme
et c'est là où les étudiants peuvent
nous aider en continuant à faire des
enquêtes des sondages
il présente une proposition à
l'assemblée générale des étudiants en
droit
leur but obtenir davantage de ressources
en santé mentale entre autres pour avoir
un meilleur accès à un psychologue
sachant qu'en ce moment pour demande
régulière les délais peuvent s'étendre
jusqu'à huit mois pour obtenir un
rendez-vous ce qui est pas pratique du
tout qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
est-ce qu'on peut aller obtenir plus de
financements combien ce que ça coûterait
pour un psychologue
bref tout ce jour des questions là
moi et nicolas proposons que lahoud et
met en place un comité
la doyenne appuient leurs projets mais
explique que sa réalisation ne dépend
pas seulement d'elle bien sûr il
faudrait plus de ressources
on s'entend là-dessus mais la faculté de
droit n'a pas de contrôle sur ces
ressources là ce qu'elle peut faire
c'est en parler avec l'équipe de
direction de l'université pour leur dire
écoutez il faudrait voir si on peut
trouver plus de ressources ou faire
pression auprès du gouvernement pour
qu'ils injectent plus de ressources dans
les universités à ses fins nous avons
communiqué avec les universités du
québec
en général elles savent qu'il ya un
détournement des psychostimulants
plusieurs font de la sensibilisation
n'ai aucune haine politique à ce sujet
si les temps le mois dernier
l'université laval a sanctionné un
étudiant qui a vendu ses médicaments
d'ordonnancé sur le campus lohan ne
prouve pas les mesures coercitives mais
cherche toujours qui montrait du doigt
je veux pas dire que les universités
sont responsables mais je veux aussi pas
dire que si les étudiants qui sont
responsables parce que ils sont un
produit de l'ain environnement il va
partager les résultats de son enquête
avec un centre d'aidé tendance de
l'université concordia pour que les
étudiants profitent de meilleurs
services en journalisme on me dit que je
dois me séparer de l'histoire que je
raconte mais je peux pas me séparer
parce que je me trouve dans une
situation où je peux aider les gens puis
c'est une question de moralité humains
et non une question de elle sait qu'un
journaliste etienne lui comptent se
débarrasser de son habitude quand il
plongera dans la vie professionnelle
mais un doute persiste parlons pas non
plus le parent sont inquiets j'en ai
joie quand faut la compression bien trop
entre soi puisque jeu
ça pourrait m'aider à faire plus de
travail je pense que je prenne tourner
vers l'est parfois quelque chose que je
peux avoir une pilule pour atteindre les
plus hauts sommets ou simplement garder
la tête hors de l'eau
pourtant elle n'est pas miraculeuse et
comporte des risques mais c'est un
raccourci attrayant dans une société de
plus en plus aux ordonnances
[Musique]
je